eighty percent of our inner dialogue is
negative and 95 of those thoughts are
the same thoughts that we had yesterday
we are beating ourselves up we were
telling ourselves that we can't do
things it's not even our friends and
family people around us telling us that
we suck it's us it's ourselves we tell
ourselves we're not good enough we can't
do this we're not strong enough smart
enough we're from the wrong country we
look the wrong way you know we're too
young we're too old whatever it is 80 of
our thoughts are negative and then 95 of
those negative thoughts are the exact
same negative thoughts that we had
yesterday it's no wonder why we stay
small it's no wonder why we stay stock
because we've created this reinforcing
Loop of negativity this is why I think
the world's biggest problem is lack of
belief I'm on a mission every day wake
up trying to make content try to spread
the message to help people believe in
themselves more I think lack of belief
is the single biggest problem in the
world wanna sword get a mentor hey it's
Nina Carmichael and we made these videos
probably because you're the most
ambitious person in your Circle but you
know you're capable of much more and you
get that Push by surround yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best my husband Evan Carmichael
and 80 of your mind is negative and
here's how you change that enjoy
and I also believe that everybody has
Michael Jordan level genius as something
like you are the greatest you're the
greatest in the world at something and
it's not what you went to school for and
it's not what your parents did for a
living probably it's something
completely different and you have to
have the courage to go off and Chase it
and find it and and do it because the
woman who solves cancer should have
already solved it by now but she never
believed in herself enough to go to
medical school and now she's a manager
an accounting firm which doesn't like
her life right I mean this is this is
where most of us are stuck most people
wake up and they drive their job that
that we don't like most people are stuck
and barely hanging on and do not like
their life and feel like they're not
contributing they're not they're not
making any kind of difference they're
not doing anything meaningful or
impactful at all in the world that's
most people imagine waking up and that's
your daily reality that may be you
or that may have been who you were and
you still Discover it and trying to
improve and get better but if 80 of
those thoughts that come through your
head conscious or unconscious are
negative I think a lot of conscious
thoughts are negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not good enough and then 95 are
the same as yesterday that we've just
created this this Loop this negative
thinking Loop
so how do we break it how do we break
free how do we solve that problem well
that's that's the billion dollar
question and that's what I wake up
every day trying to fix and I can give
you a couple things that I've worked on
and I found helpful and hopefully helps
move the needle they don't have all the
answers but but some of these might help
the first one is to change your
environment the environment makes such a
huge difference for who you are and your
daily habits and what you believe about
yourself and the environment is not just
the people who are around you although
that definitely helps you know if you've
got negative friends or family around
you you want to eliminate them
completely or spend a lot less time with
them because it's really really really
hard to have a beautiful plant grow when
it's just you know toxic waste being
poured on top of them doable but really
really difficult and so changing that
can really help and
one of the best ways I found to do it is
content
it's content it's why I make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully
you wake up today and there's a piece of
content there waiting for you whether
it's me or showcasing somebody else
across all my channels or making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just shutting off the world some of
the content that you consume just helps
you shut off the world and Escape versus
educational content that helps you learn
improve get better and solve the problem
right entertainment is let's forget
about the problem just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn to actually fix
the problem that has happened in our
life right I want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean that
entertainment doesn't exist in your life
it's not only education but if you can
shift the needle towards education to be
around the people who inspire you even
if you've never met them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence so the thing that saved
me in my first business in doing this
was modeling Bill Gates or Microsoft
when I I quit on my business partner I
struggled I didn't know you know I felt
worthless nothing was working I was
working every day and just no results in
in looking at Bill Gates's story that
that changed my life it saved my
business it allowed me to keep going
because now I had a little bit of hope
that Bill Gates could do it maybe I
could too and the more you surround
yourself with those people
the more you'll feel like you can do it
too so do an audit how many people in
your life the the actual humans that you
know and also just the people that you
subscribe to that you follow how many of
them make you feel better about yourself
and for too many people it's it's not
enough you know it's it's look at who
you follow on YouTube look at who you
subscribed to
um look at who you're connecting with on
Instagram you know if you're loading
your phone you're going through
Instagram or you're watching YouTube
videos how many times have you gone
through it and all of a sudden an hour
has gone by and you were mindlessly
watching videos or even worse make you
feel worse about yourself you ever felt
that you watch a video and then you feel
worse about yourself afterwards or
you're following somebody and it makes
you feel worse about yourself you have a
choice to unfollow those people this is
not Instagram's fault or YouTube's fault
you can take accountability here you
have a choice to unfollow those people
and then a choice to follow the people
who make you feel better about yourself
that's my aim with all these videos I
want to leave you with strategies but
also more belief in yourself at the end
of every video and if I do that I
awesome you want more belief in your
life come back you know another shot of
espresso tomorrow morning we're here and
if I don't do that cool thank you for
giving it a shot and and don't quit on
that go find somebody else who gives you
the motivation inspiration that you need
and so you can make a conscious choice
because it's so easy to stay stuck it's
so easy to stay small it's so easy to to
be the one that pours in other people
and not have anybody pour into us and
you need to make a conscious choice to
to raise your environment to change your
environment and it doesn't mean you have
to go move to a different country or
move to a fancier house or anything else
you start by just changing who you
associate with even at a mass scale
right
I've learned a lot from Steve Jobs I've
been inspired by Oprah Winfrey my
favorite entrepreneur of all time is AP
giannini who started Bank of America
these are people who I've never met
you know and and in the case of jobs in
Janine I never you know will meet
because they've passed
but I've been inspired by them and
they've made me better and they've
taught me and I've learned from them and
they've inspired me and I get courage
from them
because I've consumed their content
and you can do that too
it's just being intentional about it so
that when you raise your environment you
raise your life
the second thing is try not to do it
alone
it's really hard to go after
a goal to change your mindset to
accomplish big things when you're doing
it all by yourself you know
it this is why a lot of people quit
because you might have one one amazing
day or you watch The Right video you
have the right experience and it's like
that I want this is this is the life I
want you've ever had that right like
this is the life that I want this is who
I want to be this is this is where I
could go you have a glimpse of a
potential future that you could be it's
like I want that and you actually feel
in your heart that you can be that you
can accomplish that right has that
happen to you I know what happens the
next day you wake up and it's kind of
gone and then the next day it's
completely gone and then you're back to
your old life and the limiting beliefs
and the habits and and you know you gain
back the 20 pounds and like how did I
end up back here I thought I fixed this
right does that ever happen to you
a lot of it is because you're doing it
alone
and this took me a long time to figure
out
as an introverted person as a shy person
as somebody who doesn't like asking for
help
um
as someone who's afraid of disappointing
people
being a part of a community is not
it just sounds super scary to me
we just did our seven day challenge for
built to serve and a bunch of people
join movement makers I had almost 100
people join movement makers at the end
of it and it's people who want to be
thought leaders and want to be speakers
and authors and coaches and course
creators and membership creators and all
of this stuff there's a big impact that
spread your message and I was giving
people
a lot of uh
not just encouragement but respect like
the people who ended up joining I just
had incredible respect for
because I wouldn't have done it if I go
back to 19 year old Evan when I started
my first business I wouldn't have done
it I wouldn't have had the courage to do
it I wouldn't have joined the group we
had people sharing their videos like
tell us about your your who your why
your how is your this methodology from
the book but make a video you know
sharing your purpose and your biggest
pain of all time and some of these you
know kind of deep things that you have
to record and share and I mean it was
optional not everybody did it but in
doing that
for a lot of people it was their first
video that they've ever done
for a lot of people it's the first time
they've even shared their story to
anybody that they were sharing things in
the group that they hadn't told their
spouse
you know or their family or their best
friend and now they're making a video
in their car
sharing their story
and you see them become liberated you
see them you see them start super scared
and Afraid and unsure and fixing their
hair and you know apologizing for the
lighting not being good and them being
in the car and not knowing what they're
doing to then just seeing the
transformation of somebody
going through the Cocoon you know being
a caterpillar and turn into a butterfly
and sharing their story for the first
time and I was in awe because I I
couldn't imagine me doing that at 19
when I started my first business
I was too afraid to join a community I
was too afraid of being judged
I was too afraid of being not good
enough
and that kept me small
I kept my growth really slow
um
fortunately I kept going you know if
you've seen my my
chart on my website where I show how
much I've grown every year over year
over year over year where I've been took
five years to get the seven thousand
subscribers or something like that
and I just kept going and the one thing
that I've got was just tenacity and
drive and I will just keep going in the
face of adversity
but I made it just incredibly hard on
myself being alone not being open to
sharing with my friends what I was
struggling with and never joining the
community
so I think that can really help you you
know I think I think trying to go and
change your mindset and accomplish big
things that nobody around you has done
yet and there are some days that you
feel incredibly inspired and motivated
and Powerful it's like yeah I can do
this but you're probably not living
there most of the time
what if you did or what if you lived
kind of close to that most of the time
and point number one of raising your
environment can definitely help
but Point number two is just don't try
to do it alone
even if it's one person you don't have
to join mover makers you don't have to
join a group
but even just one person
one person who you can talk to you can
connect with
who you can you know share your stories
with not just complain to not not talk
about how hard everything is and just
have somebody to vent to but somebody
who supports you
if you had a group of people who
supported you
well you felt welcome we felt like you
weren't alone in this journey we felt
like people understood you
and we're actually genuinely cheering
you on to go you know become the person
that you want to be
Everything Changes
so raise your environment
get a community and watch your impact
happen rule number two fix your thinking
how you think about the problem is the
problem most people are locked into
losing thinking finding all the reasons
why you won't win if you're the ant
think about how you can kill the
elephant if you're the elephant think
about how you can kill the ant the
problem is not the problem how you think
about the problem is the problem so I
used to think that introverts couldn't
win I used to think that to be a good
speaker to have a YouTube channel to to
be an entrepreneur that introverts can't
win and for the longest time I hid
behind the faces on my website so before
even starting YouTube I started on my
website it was called devoncarmicle.com
I didn't have a better name at the time
and I profiled different successful
entrepreneurs basically what I do on
YouTube but on my website because I
wanted to share the stories model and
success saved my business and I wanted
to make it easier for other people to be
able to get success on their own as well
so learn who's done it apply those
strategies make it work for you and
let's go and so I always hid behind the
faces I remember my first banner I had
Howard Hughes a big Howard Hughes uh
Oprah Winfrey and a couple of people and
people kept asking me well where is Evan
Carmichael you know the website's off
your name you're putting this together
what's your story and I thought well who
cares about my story I mean sure I built
and sold my first business but it's
nothing compared to Howard Hues and
Oprah Winfrey's people have done great
things and it kept coming up over and
over and over again translate that to my
YouTube channel Evan Carmichael was
still the number one requested top ten
and when I first started doing top tens
we did Kanye West shout out to Kanye
there on the wall and then a bunch of
other people people kept asking for mine
like well what do you want mine you mean
again what have I done compared to Kanye
West and I always hid behind the fact
that I was an introvert and so I don't
want to share my story nobody is
interested I'm shy I'm I'm the
Wallflower I don't go off and try to
make myself the center of attention I
don't like you know hanging out with
people and so I had the story that
introverts Can't Win It wasn't until I
reframed it and thought you know what
introverts can win
in Communications because we're better
listeners I'm a great listener as much
as you might think I love talking and
making these videos and seeing the
speeches that I do what I love doing
more than that is listening and I think
that's how you win as an introvert
because it's not about you just sharing
sharing sharing talk talk look at me
it's you're trying to help and I've met
some amazing introverts who are on a
huge Mission and why not have a big
impact and have to fight with themselves
to get out of the comfort zone and have
the spotlight on them instead of just
being behind the scenes but they're all
great listeners they become great
communicators because they're great
listeners and so the problem wasn't that
I'm an introvert the problem is how I
thought about the problem of being an
introvert so how can you fix your
thinking about the problems in your life
I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help step
number one is ask yourself what is the
single biggest problem you're facing
right now right now in your life in your
business what do you think is the number
one problem that is holding you back
either write it down or hold it in your
mind what is that big problem for me I
thought it's because I am an introvert
what's yours the second thing is how
will you change your thinking so you
have that problem guess what lots of
people have that same problem and are
off crushing it the only reason why
you're not is the story that you're
telling yourself and so what is the
change in thinking that you want to make
so for me is that being an introvert I
can win because I'll be a better
listener and that's how I'll leverage
being an introvert to be a good
communicator how are you going to change
your thinking and then step number three
is have play bigger triggers play bigger
triggers is a term I came up with to
describe things that are in your
environment that make you play bigger so
putting this on makes me play bigger
having the Doritos here damn the Doritos
makes you play bigger the people behind
me right Kanye over there and all these
people makes me play bigger the awards
down there and the neck brace on the on
the cabinet and and the videos that I
make they're all play bigger triggers
what it means is you set something up
once and then it reminds you
consistently every day that you're
supposed to be playing at a higher level
so that change that you want to make you
have the problem that you have you have
the change that you want to make what
are the play bigger triggers that you
want to create so that you can set them
up once physical environment it's
screens on your desktop and and cell
phone and habits and routines that
you're going to do daily so that you
don't have to remind yourself all the
time like oh yeah I'm trying to do this
you have elements in your environment
that are hitting you with it every
single day showing you that it's
possible and making you play bigger also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three get excuses out
of your way most people focus on the
problem instead of the solution and that
is why they failed I like to say that
there are a million reasons why your
ideas will never work out and only eight
why they will either way you're right so
it's better to focus on the eight Your
Heroes the people that you look up to
the people that you love and want to be
like right Your Heroes all succeeded
with less than what you currently have
right now if they can all do it so can
you the only thing in your way are your
excuses so one of the things that I love
most about both my wife and my team is
that they're always willing to find the
way one of the things that Nina loves
most about herself I had her fill out
this form maybe two years ago of like
what do you love most about yourself and
at the top was she's a fast learner she
loves learning new things she loves
taking on new challenges and I love that
I love that about her and I love that in
people I think you should be a fast
learner I think you should love learning
I think you should always be taking on
New Opportunities right now my YouTube
channel I've split up my channel into
eight or nine different channels and
then just recently I split them up again
where we launched a top 10 Channel just
for the top 10 videos so the top 10
videos aren't on my main Channel anymore
and uh then we're doing an everything
Channel where if you just want all the
content it's all on one spot so it's
chaos it's crazy my whole team has to be
restructured and everybody's taking on
new projects and responsibilities and
we're supposed to have a one month
transition phase to do it but that was
the recommendation that was that was the
aggressive recommendation does it have a
one month transition period and for me
one month just as death it's just death
I mean I said okay great one month but
then as I'm into it on the Tuesday of
like the first week like guys we need to
launch like this weekend
[Laughter]
the problems and yes we're gonna make so
many mistakes and people aren't trained
properly and there's more work and we
need to you know we figure out who wants
to do what and how so many issues
awesome let's go
I think about Rey for example on my team
who
has been doing all these thumbnails so I
have a I have a set design for my top 10
rules thumbnails that people love and
it's it's been going like that for years
and I've always been on my team to say I
don't care that everybody thinks their
thumbnails are great they can be better
how do we make them better and so
finally finally after years of testing
we finally found the format that would
win that would that would beat our
original thumbnails and there's minor
differences we zoom in on the face we
got rid of the second logo make the text
bigger minor differences and then Rey
has been going back and updating split
tests doing against their old videos and
we have 13 1400 different split tests on
our videos it's crazy I think I split
test more than anybody on YouTube so
he's going back and updating all the old
thumbnails
and trying to prove a winner each time
and he's maybe I don't know halfway
through he's like think about how many
videos we have on the channel we've got
6 000 videos a lot of them are our top
10.
now with this change I found a new
format
we found a new format a new thumbnail
different color scheme different text
different pictures
different logo new thumbnail format and
we found that it's working and so I said
Ray
I know you just changed all the
thumbnails
we gotta do it again it's like this is
so exciting let's go I love this guy so
much right where most people what are
they they're gonna complain they're
gonna say I just did all this work or
this other thing right
you don't want to be around people like
that and you definitely don't want to be
that for too many people the problem is
for so many people that's you that's not
even people around you that's you you're
thinking about all the sunk costs that
you put into something you're thinking
about invested so much into this thing
and and now you want me to shift
everything
yep
you need to be on the yep side now you
need to adopt that kind of mindset that
kind of personality that just because I
work before it doesn't mean it's going
to keep working you find something new
it's better let's go this is what the
whole game is about so how do you do it
how do you be more resourceful I'm going
to give you a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is focus
on the eight so I said at the beginning
there are a million reasons why it's not
going to work out and if you talk to
your friends and family and and social
media they'll find a million more
reasons why it's not going to work out
great there's a million reasons why it's
not going to work out
now there's two million and there's
eight while it will
only focused on the eighth focus on the
eighth be be rigid be disciplined stop
thinking about those negative things are
still there awesome those reasons sure
are awesome great I'm only focused on
the eight
I don't care about all the reasons why
it's not gonna work out
that that's that's where most of the
world lives that's the land of
negativity I'm here and it's a small
Lane it's easier there's only eight
reasons why you want to win I'm just
gonna pick those eight and focus on that
that's it choose it's a choice
you're right either way right you are
right if you say I'm not gonna win
because I don't have the education and
the resources and the money and the
parents and you're right
you've already decided you're right yes
absolutely you're right but
people with less resources less
connections less ideas less Talent less
skills than you they've done it
you're just full of excuses if you want
to believe the excuses then you have
already lost if you want to buy into the
eight reasons why you're gonna win and
surround yourself with your Heroes who
have done it and that's a daily source
of inspiration for you to keep going off
and doing it then you will win focus on
the eight not the Million number two is
model success
this is what really helped me I mean now
I have I have all these channels and
we're modeling success all day long and
I've built an entire business around
this but this is the thing that saved my
business from the from the first start
right like Bill Gates how he built
Microsoft saved my company
right learning from his story made me
finally start to have some success in my
business and then from there every
morning I would I would read a little
bit about a successful entrepreneur
now I'd much rather watch a video than
read
um but hack your own Luna style maybe
you prefer to listen to podcasts I
listen to zero podcasts because I'm not
an auditorial learner learning how to
model success finding people who've done
the thing that you want to do does two
things one it gives you hope seeing what
they came from like go look at Oprah's
story see what she came from
and then for you to say that you have
less resources less available to you
than Oprah did at the time that she was
growing up is ludicrous is crazy you're
way more equipped just because you have
the internet than Oprah ever did when
she was getting started
but maybe you hate Oprah awesome great
who do you want to learn from Jeff Bezos
awesome go look at his story look at the
people who you look up to your Heroes
study them not how they make an extra
million dollars now but zero to one how
did they get started what did they have
to go through learn from them
study them and it gives you inspiration
to know that it's possible and it gives
you strategies because chances are what
work for them could also work for you it
won't work for you 100 it's like trying
on this cowboy hat that's just a little
bit too oversized and you gotta you
gotta tweak it and take in some of the
sides maybe add a little bit more
stitching somewhere so that it fits but
modern success takes you eighty percent
of the way you don't have to come up
with all the genius ideas yourself the
model's been proven go out copy it apply
it to yourself and start winning and
step number three is tell yourself this
is just a warm-up I love this strategy I
think this is one of the greatest things
you can ever do for your self-confidence
self-love self-respect is whenever it's
difficult whenever it's hard whenever
you're at your Breaking Point whenever
you're like I don't know if I can keep
going
tell yourself this is just the warm-up
this is just a warm-up I'm capable of
way more than this
and what it does is it actually tricks
your brain a little bit to believe in it
and now you've just broken through a
comfort zone now you've broken through
it to another level of Excellence you've
just raised your standards a little bit
higher it's extremely powerful so let's
think about it if that thing that is all
consuming all encompassing is all you're
capable of doing right now
that's the problem that means you're
never going to grow Beyond this thing
right you're you're never going to scale
and become something bigger because this
is the max that you're capable of doing
and I remember talking to Alex who helps
me run trying to dance salsa and what he
was stressing out about and we have big
Ambitions for this business we have we
have big Ambitions for where Toronto Dan
salsa needs to be and Alex needs to be
the guy to lead it
if this little thing that that feels
all-encompassing right but if this
little thing owns you you're never gonna
get here
so tell yourself this is just a warm-up
I'm capable of way more than this way
more than this is the beginning this is
baby steps I'm way stronger than this
tell yourself that you say it out loud
tell yourself this is just a warm-up
like that put your hand down it's just a
warm-up
say that three times and see how you
feel and then get to work because you
know what it is just a warm up and
you're capable of way more let's go rule
number four take control of your
decisions every time you say I can't
you're teaching yourself that you suck
because you've quit because you've given
up it's not your fault that you can't do
it it's your work or your school or your
family or all the other commitments that
you have but not your fault nope
nope
nope change your I can't to either I'm
going to or I choose not to that's how
you take back control of your decisions
and your life so I recently listened to
this Chinese song and I got obsessed
with it I got obsessed with it I was
playing it all day long and I just I
loved I don't know what they're saying I
don't know which I don't know what the
words mean I just loved I loved it I
loved it I go to bed and lyrics start
coming to me rap lyrics
in full sentences right the first one
comes in okay wake up I'm in bed I'm
lying in bed trying to sleep you know
it's 11 o'clock trying to suggest an
idea rap lyric come okay I write it down
again Rattlers come write it down more
and more and more write it down until
three in the morning I haven't slept yet
ideas just keep coming for this song
that's like I need to make a rap
and then what comes into my head is that
what you can make a rap
it's easy to get locked in into I can't
mode I can't do this I can't start that
I can't do a rap I didn't go to school
for that not that you go to school for
rap you know I didn't rap growing up I
don't have musical Talent right that's
not what people know me for that's how
people expect for me I can't rap
foreign
that's where most people quit
but instead I decided I was gonna get up
at three something in the morning go to
my computer finish writing out my lyrics
and then I spent the day rapping and
that night finished the video sent it
off to uh Christina my Editor to put it
together and the next day we released my
rap video now maybe you love it maybe
you hate it it's gotten some decent
responses it was tons of fun to put
together and most importantly I taught
myself in all of these things these are
all great micro moments to teach
yourself that you're amazing
whenever you say I can't and you do it
that's how you build self-confidence
that's that's the birthplace of
self-confidence self-love self-respect
is taking something that you think that
you can't do and just trying
not even doing it full out because I
don't expect my rap to go off and win
any kind of awards right but I tried it
I did it I released it expect the second
beginning that's okay it's normal it's
part of the process but in those moments
of I can't and then turning them into
something that actually exists
is where your Genius will come
I look at my top 10 series and partly
why I have Kanye on my wall because the
first video that I made was on Kanye
first top 10 was on Kanye was five years
into my YouTube career
I did a response to my friend Mark
Draeger
from Phantom media and I said initially
I can't do this like I can't make a
video now on this I have all these other
commitments I have a full day ahead of
other stuff that I'm supposed to do and
said no I did action I'm just gonna do
it forget it I'm gonna make it and I
didn't expect it to do well
luckily it actually did and then that
became this whole thing of making I
don't know how many top tens hundreds
maybe a thousand I don't know how many
top ten how many top times have I done I
have no idea
but it started off as this idea
trust your ideas
know that they're amazing
stop saying I can't to yourself this is
where you need to take control of your
head and your heart you have to make
decisions with your heart and then use
your head to figure out how to do it
anytime you're doing something new super
important anytime you're doing something
new I'm making it I'm gonna make a wrap
I'm gonna make a top 10 video I'm gonna
do anything outside my normal thing
right same for you anytime you're doing
something new it doesn't make sense
because it's new what is brand new
doesn't make sense you're creating
something new and so your head your
logical brain that's designed to keep
you safe doesn't understand it its job
is to to protect you and says don't do
that you can't do that
because one has never been done and
because we have all these reasons why
it's not possible for you not just
anybody else for you you can't do it
because you haven't done it before
that's what your head says your heart
can create something new your heart
creates art your heart makes up a world
that hasn't existed before and so at the
very beginning of many projects you're
having your heart are against each other
your heart's saying I want to make this
your heads you can't make this
and so you end up staying stuck in limbo
with all these ideas never taking
momentum because your your head and your
heart are fighting you've got your foot
on the gas and the break at the same
time never moving knowing that you're
capable of more and so you make the big
decisions in your life with your heart
and then you rally your head to say okay
we're doing this I'm making the rap
video I'm making the top ten you're
gonna do your crazy idea and then your
head says ooh okay they're serious let's
figure out how not to die doing this
right let's figure out how to actually
make it work
so you make the big decisions in life
with the heart and then you use your
head to figure out how to go out and
accomplish it so how do you stop saying
I can't and turn your ideas into action
I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help step
number one is say I can't
and then have a blank and then fill in
that blank like what can't you do right
now I can't and not some stupid thing
like I can't fly I can't jump off a
building okay great like what are your
actual goals what do you want to
accomplish in your life accomplish with
your business what do you want to have
happen within that context what are you
telling yourself that I can't do so when
you say I can't and you leave a space
there what's the person that comes to
your mind if you need help if you're not
getting it go look in the mirror
seriously pause this video go to the
mirror look at yourself in the eyes and
say I can't and then see what comes up
whether you actually stayed out loud or
it's just in your head that little voice
inside your head that is also powerful
what is it saying that you cannot do
write it down step number two is you're
gonna do it
Do It Whatever the thing is do it you
can't rap rap you can't make a top ten
make a top ten you can't whatever do it
like the smallest possible way if it's
make a wrap I don't expect a fully
polished amazing video right the two
percent difference take that idea that
you have and instead of planning to get
to 100 the two percent difference is
figure out what is the first two percent
of that idea and just do it you say you
can't do it great do it
the difference between doing something
and not doing something is doing
something
just go do it show yourself this this
could be the greatest day of your life
if you take something this is what you
want to train yourself like if you say I
can't do that if you're in the habit of
saying I can't I can't I can't
you need to flip that that's not again
some Monumental thing
some giant event that happens it's in
the daily it's a daily battle with
yourself confidence comes from the daily
battle with yourself a flipping I can't
to showing yourself that you can try
that you will you're gonna do it so do
it whatever that I can't is go do it
find some spot away and just do it and
in Step number three is expect to suck
expect to suck don't expect to be great
if if you say I can't make videos and
then you go do one expect it to suck
that's okay that doesn't mean
see I can't do it look it sucked no no
no no you tying yourself Worth to the
results is a losing game it's the
process you started all that's missing
now is a skill set how do you get a
skill set practice
if I suck at making rap but every day I
worked at my rap skills I would be
better
I may not win a Grammy but I could I
could spit out some fire rap I just
believe it and I want you to believe
that too that whatever they're saying
you might think that's ridiculous that
Evan Carmichael thinks she could be a
rapper
that's what I want for you because
everybody's saying that you are
ridiculous you're thinking that you can
become an ex and worse than that you are
saying that it's ridiculous for you to
become an ex
you can be an ex
practice dedication hard work it's just
a skill set the thing that's missing is
momentum momentum comes from the belief
that is possible
so you can't what you can't X do it and
expect to suck and prove to yourself
that you're capable of starting you're
capable of building momentum and that
now that the only thing missing is a
skill set and just like any other skill
you can pick it up through practice
rule number five the last one before our
very special bonus clip lose the
scarcity mindset you are staying small
because you are afraid you're afraid of
the worst case scenario coming true
losing having no money and being
embarrassed but you know you're capable
of more you know the way that you're
going about doing things right now is
nothing compared to what you're capable
of unless you lose that scarcity mindset
you're always gonna stay small knowing
that you are capable of more today I'm
going to show you how so one of the
easiest ways to get out of your scarcity
mindset is to go from idea to action as
soon as you get an idea you do something
about it and sometimes that idea often
that idea is going to be too big too
scary too crazy you can't do it who are
you to do this you don't have the money
resources time connections energy right
all of that all of the excuses that come
into your head I like to teach myself
that as soon as I get an idea I go do
something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust them go do something so this
is great this is a grant video because
when I did my tour in 2019 that's
January to April we hit 23 different
cities over 90 days and at the beginning
I was trying to find different sponsors
that would help out with travel
accommodations because it was me Nina my
film guy Danny and and all of our gear
was mostly Danny's gear
lighting and we had speakers and camera
gear and all of this stuff and we ended
up renting a suburban and driving across
America but before doing that I emailed
Grant and I said hey Grant
uh
can I use your plane for 90 days
for my tour
and to his credit
the email that he wrote back was what's
the upside not no not forget about it
not do you know how much it costs and
just jet fuel and and you know my pilot
and then I can't use my plane for three
months he said what's the upside I said
well listen I'm gonna let everybody in
my audience know about you and listen we
didn't get a deal we didn't make it
happen but it's that it's that idea of
going for my data action
right and I still do a lot with Grant
right making this video helping promote
all the stuff that he's up to we're
looking at doing something together when
I go to Miami next
and so that one exchange didn't ruin the
relationship and I'm happy to share it
publicly
maybe that's embarrassing for some
people right but the idea of trusting
your ideas you get an idea you go do
something it may be too big it may be it
may be scary you might have people say
no even if the most likely answer is no
right the most likely answer might be no
the most likely answer to me asking
grant that question is no right it's a
no but if I don't ask it's a no 100
don't take the no away from somebody
else
it might be 99.999 now but there's still
a little chance maybe there's a Yes
somewhere in there trust your ideas do
something I did and so continue to do
and that's how you escape scarcity
mindset that's how you escape playing
small and actually go down and Chase the
life that you want to live so let's get
more specific I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is idea to action
so as soon as you get that idea you
don't judge it you don't think about it
you don't say why me you just go and you
do something find the smallest possible
way to just get started right so you
just trust that the idea came to you I
believe that ideas flow through you you
got that idea for a reason why are you
thinking about it don't worry about why
you're thinking about it just go do
something about it find the smallest
possible way to just go do something
about it you are a genius therefore you
come up with genius ideas not all of
them work out maybe the timing was wrong
maybe the execution was wrong but it's
still a great idea because you came up
with it therefore it is a great idea and
you have to go do something about it so
trust your ideas and go from idea action
step number two is what I call the two
percent difference here's what happens
most of the time when people come up
with an idea you default into planning
mode planning strategy thinking
researching and then you wake up the
next day and you're back to square one
you're back to normal like the energy
that you got the boldness the courage
that you had is gone because you woke up
the next day
so you've wasted your best time your
best momentum that Peak in energy on
planning where what I want you to do is
use that for Action so the two percent
difference is instead of planning to get
to 100 which is what most of us will do
you come up with an idea and then plan
how it's going to happen 100 to finish
line so you know what the finish line is
going to be stop thinking you even know
where it's going to be instead of
worrying about 100 focus on the first
two percent
the first two percent I have this idea
what can I do right now right now that
will get me two percent of the way
right
you wanna you wanna make a YouTube video
great pull your phone and start
recording that's two percent you want to
remind yourself to breathe this is one
thing we have on our on our door every
time I leave the door every time I leave
my condo there's a sign that says
breathe right because I want to remind
myself to breathe take take practice my
Wim Hof take 30 breaths in in and out as
I walk outside my condo every time
I put that there was a as a play bigger
trigger for myself but it's easy to
think well if I'm gonna put a sign on my
door then I need it to be a certain size
and I need to be the perfect picture and
I need it to be framed and you make it
bigger and then you don't do anything
that's the biggest problem you just
don't have momentum you're not doing
enough
and so step number one the two percent
difference is
I took out a sticky note and I just
wrote breathe and I stuck it on my door
and it's a reminder every day to breathe
that doesn't mean that you can't go back
and plan doesn't mean that you can't
replace it with something nicer bigger
better yes of course planning has its
role but not as a first step your first
step is action if your first step is
planning you're losing
if your first step is planning that's
why you're a perfectionist that's why
you don't have momentum happening
against your ideas your first step
idea into the first two percent and then
step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result this is
where again so many entrepreneurs will
fail because you tied your self-worth to
the outcome of you accomplishing that
thing if you woke up and you only did
things that you knew you were going to
win at You're Gonna Play small for life
you're only doing things inside your
comfort zone because you know you're
gonna win at them right or a very high
degree chance you're gonna win if that's
all you ever take on you play small for
life
but if you're going outside your comfort
zone taking on new projects growing as a
human learning getting better checking
on new challenges that are bigger and
Beyond you most days you're actually
going to wake up and fail because you're
doing something new
but if you woke up every day and were
proud of the effort you were putting in
you're proud of yourself for the effort
you put in your max effort you're trying
to make the best video you can you're
trying to make the best product or
service you can you're proud of yourself
for the effort every single day
you're going to create amazing things
Way Beyond what you thought you're
capable of and way more than the person
who just sits inside their bubble doing
things that they know they're going to
win it
tie yourself forth to the effort not the
results
why do you get depressed after you
accomplish a goal you celebrate a goal
for five minutes and then you're sad why
is that it's because you had the wrong
goal your goal should not be to climb to
the top of the mountain because the only
spot left is to go down your goal should
be to climb forever you never stop
climbing you're on a mission you're
trying to save the world stop asking
when can I stop you don't you don't want
to you want to climb forever you don't
want to stop not now not ever because
you are on a mission so one of my
biggest fears is the Aging rock star I
look at some of these rock stars who
made it big when they're in their 20s or
30s and then as they get into their 40s
50s sometimes even 60s they're still
playing which is great they're still on
tour which is awesome but what are the
songs that they're singing the songs
that they're singing are still the ones
that they came up with when they're in
their 20s or 30s and I can't imagine
that I can't imagine coming up with a
video so in my 20s did I was I on
YouTube in my 20s I was 10 years ago
right April
2009 I was on nine wow I'm getting old
April 2009 yes April 2009 so it was 29
when my first video went up great if I'm
still showing that video all the time if
I'm still showing my 40th video then
that's the one that hit I just feel like
it's such a letdown I mean it's great
that you're still on tour it's great
that you're still being asked to to get
on stage but to sing the same songs over
and over and over again for me I'm not
trying to judge or say that they suck
for me I'm terrified of that I don't
want that to be me I don't want to think
of the video that I made last year is my
best video ever and all I'm gonna do for
the rest of my life is just play that
same video over and over and over and
over again I want to climb forever
I want to challenge myself to come up
with new stories each time whenever
possible making these kind of videos I
want to always push the envelope I want
to always discover new formats and when
I always look at splitting up my Channel
or bringing them all back together or
launching a course always always
something new always climbing I don't
see it as this Mountaintop there is no
mountain top you're on the staircase and
you're climbing forever and you're never
gonna get to the top you don't want to
get to the top that's that's sadness
that's despair when you've accomplished
everything there is to accomplish you
hate your life that sucks you celebrate
this is what happens for high Achievers
right you celebrate for five minutes
like man we did it and then it's a big
letdown when I crossed 2 million
subscribers on my YouTube channel a
million subscribers I didn't want to
celebrate like because the day-to-day is
a celebration because this is I'd rather
this is a celebration this making this
video right here this is my celebration
moment
the process the actual part of climbing
right I'm trying to get better every
single time 6 000 videos later still
going when do I stop I don't I want to
make six million videos right
my goal of hitting a billion
entrepreneurs I don't actually want to
hit a billion entrepreneurs I want to
have a goal so big that I never do it
and so I don't want to be that Asian
rock star I hope that when I'm 95 years
old
I may you know not have my mind totally
there my body might be giving up on me
but I'm hoping I'm hoping that I'm still
trying to push the envelope still trying
to do more do my best and maybe if I get
lazy complacent slow if I start
complaining you catch me complaining
when I'm 95 years old show me this video
back show me this video and say look
look you've become what you said you
didn't want to become right hold me
accountable I think as soon as you stop
growing you're dying
and I think that's why so many people
are unhappy because they've actually
stopped growing a long time ago
and so don't be the Asian rock star I
don't want it for me I don't want it for
you either so how do you do it how do
you stay active how do you stay growing
I'm going to give you three steps that I
think will help step number one is have
an environment of Excellence how do you
get out of complacency have an
environment of Excellence right think
about the people that are around you
your physical environment this right I
walk into this I walk into this these
all mean something to me right this this
bag of Doritos means something to me no
they're not a sponsor these people all
mean something to me they may not mean
anything to you but they mean something
to me what's on the background of your
cell phone what's in the background of
your desktop right your environment you
set it up once
a physical environment you set it up
once and then it reminds you it reminds
you every day when you walk into it that
I need to continue to Stamp Out
complacency that I need to no matter how
big a game I think I'm playing I'm
sitting here working right I got Steve
Jobs iron me down right here I got AP
giannini eyeing me down right here every
time I walk away I got my parents
looking at me right Howard Schultz Kanye
West it's impossible to stay complacent
because these people are staring me down
right think about the people in your
life the people who you're hanging out
with a lot of the friends that you have
often will let you off the hook because
they have lower standards than you do
they'll say it's okay don't go off and
do that thing it's okay you deserve a
break you deserve a rest and then maybe
maybe you do maybe you're too tired
right there are points like when I broke
my neck I couldn't do some things that's
okay right there are times you need to
be gentle in yourself but more often
than not you actually need to be hard on
yourself you need to push yourself
forward when you're friends with lower
standards than you
let you off the hook and you want to say
yes to it and you do you've let yourself
down you need this you need an
environment of Excellence physical
environment the media you consume the
videos you watch the people around you
that's how you stop staying complacent
step number two is chart your start so
having a good morning routine no matter
how energetic I am right now right like
this is amazing I'm so excited making
videos for you guys I'm pumped up this
legit feeling of warmth energy gratitude
to be here making this video for you I
love it I can wake up tomorrow I'm gonna
be tired all right I'm gonna wake up
tomorrow and I gotta get my stuff done I
I gotta you know I'm just I'm tired I
got stuff in my eyes I got lines in my
face I'm tired
what you do in the morning sets you up
for the whole day and so the most
important part of your morning routine
is the thing that makes you sore you
might have a morning routine you'll be
saying whatever I already have more
morning routine awesome great chances
are it's actually not working for you
chances are the morning routine that you
have right now is barely working for you
it's the crumbs of what should be
working for you
the most important thing out of a
morning routine is how do you feel at
the end of it how do you feel
do you feel bold Unstoppable energetic
confident ready to take on the day and
it's a yes and eat a good job if it's a
no then you need to go back and do it
again or you need to change something
dramatically in your routine too many
people just check the box a check in the
box I watch the video yes I checked the
box but I was doing it while eating
breakfast and washing dishes and getting
my kids ready for school and whatever
else you were doing so you weren't
actually paying attention you didn't get
the feeling
and so just checking the Box isn't
enough
you can maybe even shorten your morning
routine maybe cutting it in half but if
you get the feeling attached to it you
feel bold powerful confident Unstoppable
every morning your life is gonna change
if you wake up every day and do the
thing that makes you feel bold powerful
Unstoppable confident every morning your
life will change will not be the same
one year from today I promise you chart
your start change your morning routine
and number three is tell me I suck this
is one of the favorite things that I
love doing whenever there's somebody
that I want to learn from whenever
there's somebody that I think has more
knowledge than me who could teach me
something I'll always go and say tell me
why I suck tell me why I suck even if I
feel like I'm great at it great tell me
why I suck when I'm looking at my
YouTube channel anytime I go to a
YouTube event people who might have
feedback for me I say tell me why my
channel sucks just like destroy why do I
suck
and and no it's not because I love
punishment it's because I want to give
permission to people to be honest you're
talking about avoiding complacency this
is how you do it you need honest
feedback on how to get better
and so people are afraid of telling you
the truth no matter what kind of
permission you're trying to set up for
them most of the time people are still
afraid because they're not sure how
you're going to react to it maybe your
closest friends will tell you but people
who you look up to people who are
experts people who might be able to help
you if they don't know you super well
will be afraid to give you honest
feedback because they don't want to hurt
your feelings because they don't know
who you are but if you lead with tell me
why I suck at this
why I suck
right what that does is gives them
permission to be honest because chances
are here's what they're going to say
well you don't suck I mean you did a
great job but you know what
here are three things that I think you
could really work on and chances are if
you didn't lead with something like that
to say tell me why I suck they would
only tell you one thing out of the three
and you're probably missing those two
the two that they're afraid to tell you
are the two that you actually need to
hear
so whenever you find somebody who has
something to teach you who's going to
push you outside your comfort zone who's
gonna make you grow and stop being
complacent
start that sentence with them with tell
me why I suck
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue typically I
will see you there it takes a giant
effort to overcome your environment you
definitely can it's definitely possible
tons of people are doing it but it takes
that giant effort to say I don't want to
stay stuck